I mean I am dyslexic and and therefore I
think I've been very good at keeping
things simple because you know as a
dyslexic I need to need things to be
simple for myself and therefore virgin I
think you know when we launched a
financial service company or a bank you
know we do not use jargon it's
everything is very clear-cut very simple
and and I think people you know people
have an affinity to the Virgin brand
because we don't you know we don't talk
above them or talk down to them I think
a lot of people do not have the courage
to try to start a business and all I was
saying I've written a book called screw
it just do it and and it basically is
trying to say to people just give it a
try
and she sometimes a very very small
amount of money is all that's needed to
start a company I mean my mother founded
a bracelet on the street and she handed
into the police station and after three
months the police there to sell it and
you know the the couple of hundred
dollars was really critical at a
critical time in the development of our
business so it's always safe just to
give it give it again and good luck on
that you just watched two amazing clips
with Sir Richard Branson take the next
three minutes and sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]